from Rasmussen 35 of Democrats think RFK
JR could win the latest transmission
report national telephone and online
survey found 49 of likely as voters have
a favorable impression of our RFK Jr
including 14 with a very favorable
opinion 38 view Kennedy unfavorably
including 18 with a very unfavorable
impression while another 14 are not sure
so uh this is it you know we're not
we're not we don't have the rest of the
data that's that's the the general idea
right here
RFK Juniors polling in the double digits
we're seeing something interesting a lot
of people have suggested this could be
our last election both on the left and
the right or maybe
maybe
2020 was our last
sort of election I guess with ballot
harvesting and all the rules being
changed and all the and coveted lockdown
can you really even call it maybe 2016
was the last because whatever is coming
up in 2024 it'll approximate an election
yeah like 2020 did but it's going to be
very very weird so there will be
something but you're gonna have what RFK
Jr Trump who I mean who who are the
candidates going to be the fact is the
Santa's people don't want to vote Trump
trump people don't want to vote to
Santas they are fighting to an extreme
degree you've got the media smearing RFK
Junior to an extreme degree but he's
pulling in double digits near 20 is
consistently around 20 it seems like the
system's starting to fracture in a bunch
of different ways so it's hard to know
exactly who's going to win but I did see
another poll that said Democrats are
more likely to vote third party than
Republicans which suggests a trump
Victory because if RFK Jr runs an
independent you know not getting the
Democratic nomination or if they put
Biden in it's it then it will split the
Democrat vote yeah do you think RFK Jr
would run as independent or will they
pull a Bernie there's all kinds of
reports that he's considering running
independent he hasn't told me personally
what he's gonna do but he might as well
I mean he has so much uh momentum
there's no reason if he has the funding
there's no reason for him not to and do
you think the Democrats would let him
touch the debate stage no you don't
think so no of course not I mean look
they cut Andrew Yang's microphone yeah I
remember that sir that was hilarious
well I mean you can't put Biden on a
debate statement there's no way that he
would be able I mean already I'm trying
to find the numbers right now but uh a
significant number of Democrats
Democrats Phil Biden is too old so yes
there's infighting the Republicans but
the Democrats don't want their most
likely uh incumbent nominee right now I
mean this is not looking good for me and
I'm not uh a political consultant by any
means but RFK can only benefit even if
he doesn't end up being the Democratic
nominee why not just push forward so
many moderates are looking at him like
Hey this guy's interesting the same way
that there are moderates who didn't
think of themselves as any particular
party who ended up voting for Trump
because they felt like he represented
something I think RFK in some way could
win ground back for the Democrats not
every single one but I think that he
represents something the Democrats
haven't had in a long time there's a lot
of Boomers I think that would would that
would appeal to him or that would he
would appeal to just because of the fact
that he's a Kennedy uh Adrian Curry made
this great or called him this great
thing and I I picked up from her that
the son of Camelot there's a lot of
people that are older that are older Gen
X and and Boomers that still hearken
back to that you know the Camelot era
the the way that they looked at uh the
Kennedys and and all that stuff and a
lot of the stuff that he's saying is the
stuff that people that are fairly
anti-government get into even he's got a
lot of influence even in the libertarian
party
um which personally I don't understand
it so much other than his anti-war and
anti like kind of pharmaceutical stance
um or at least skepticism but I do think
that he would appeal to a significant
portion of the older Democrats yeah he
doesn't have the same Progressive Edge
in some ways I mean look at what's going
on right now he is spending all of his
time in New Hampshire he's focused there
where is Biden going to concentrate
South Carolina the Democratic the the D
Triple C is already saying we want South
Carolina to primary first and this is
really upsetting New Hampshire's voters
and they they are saying you are going
to give the states to Republicans
obviously they don't carry a lot of
electoral votes on the other hand they
are traditionally the first in the
nation so Kennedy saying I'm going to
focus on you guys you are the state that
I I will pay attention to shows uh an
interest in keeping with some traditions
and some balances of power that the
Biden wing of the Democrat Party is
willing to abandon what if it is RFK I
mean you look Biden can't campaign he
can't travel around the country no I
mean the the big news which we'll get
into in a second is that he's got CPAP
marks on his face now he's 80 years old
the dude is unwell and we've known he's
been he's got metal plates in his head
he can't talk straight he can't travel
around this country RFK Junior Canada
what is he 69 years old yeah he's also
fit got that video of him you know doing
the his lift bench press bench pressing
yeah and uh
he's going to be able to go around and
get votes he's gonna be able to build
his profile he does have a difficult
time speaking though with all due
respect and and that matters but he's
still been able to he's still going to
be able to get those ideas across he's
still gonna be able to go on podcasts do
Town Halls Biden cannot I think how
could Gavin Newsom beat someone like RFK
Jr true and I think even with I'm not
sure what to call it maybe a speech
impediment with the RFK has you you hear
it once you get used to it with Biden he
just yeah doesn't have any actual
cohesive thoughts I mean there is there
is not it would be terrifying to put him
on it yeah he doesn't have a speech
impediment the lights are literally out
whereas RFK junior is a really smart guy
but do you you know Tucker last night
came out and basically made the
prediction on his Twitter show that it's
going to be Gavin Newsom and as a
California that scares me uh to death
like you you think you think RFK JR
could be Gavin yes really absolutely
okay I mean isn't uh do you think the
establishment
well no no no no I'm saying
if you were to places yeah if you put
Gavin Newsom on stage with RFK Jr FK
Junior wins no question I totally agree
now whether or not the establishment the
machine the media would allow something
like that to happen is an entirely
different question yeah yeah so uh but I
think in terms of I think Trump would
have a hard time debating RFK Jr yeah RK
Jr is doing a fantastic job he's got
he's got Trump supporters being like we
like this guy and people actually saying
Trump RFK Jr or Trump Kennedy is the
ticket yeah I mean it should be
legendary yeah I mean seriously yeah
massive yeah I I mean
that'd be great if elon's right about it
being like the funniest outcome being
the most likely then then bring it on
then Trump Kennedy well he he got that
Twitter spaces where he had uh Kelly
Slater on it Tulsi gabbard like all of
these people that sort of represent this
anti-establishment Wing that's not even
tied to a political party it's just a
cultural sentiment happening so when you
have the best surfer in the world that's
getting like Twitter spaces yeah dude he
was on the he was invited to the spaces
and so when you have the best surfer in
the world like backing a political
candidate and then Jack Dorsey comes out
and offers that support too so it's a
very interesting Coalition he's building
and uh it is interesting though you go
back to the libertarian side of him that
on issues like Pharmaceuticals he is pro
2A at least he says but then he's hype
not always and they're old lips that are
coming out now where he's like okay dude
but on top of that like he's super big
government on issues of environmentalism
it's like okay so are you a green New
Deal president because that's yeah he
probably is and there are a lot of
people who are probably saying yes I
want that there are probably a lot of
Democrats who know that Biden can't win
and absolutely would vote for off Cajun
you're probably older ones the younger
ones they just believe whatever they
hear in the median it's laughably sad
not all of them but a lot of them it is
a kind of weird thing right you find
like older Democrats won't believe you
when you tell them what the media says
and younger Democrats believe whatever
the media says we're raised on TV their
parents have been putting them in front
of the TV they just trusted it's like
having another adult in their lives uh I
also think they have made it so
distrusting the media is a right-wing
thing and so if it's trendy to be
left-wing you can't uh well that's what
you don't have to trust that's what you
were saying if if uh Joe Biden
hypothetically is in his bathroom and
stumbles out of the shower to grab his
dog's tail and then breaks his ankle if
you report that in any way that's
negative they'll call you right wing
I was like but that's that's the thing
that happened you know yeah and by the
way shouldn't shouldn't everybody be
concerned about his age if he were to
run again he played 85 at the end of his
next term so it's no way he can run no
he's going to beat his own record as the
nation's oldest president yeah but but
we've long speculated that they will
criminally charge Joe Biden he will get
indicted and he will get arrested maybe
on the documents maybe on the corruption
and then they'll say we're not biased
we're going after Trump and Joe Biden
clearing the way for someone like Newsom
538 has them at a
54.8 percent disapproval rating right
now in a 4 out of 10 approval wow so
it's like historically bad it's like I
think only only behind a Carter right I
mean it's it's awful and it's been awful
all the time and he's not doing anything
to make it better I mean right now he's
on his tour about broadband internet
which is interesting and great but you
actually can't have him talk at all
because and this feels so distrustful to
say but he is ill he is not okay he is
not capable of being compelling even
with uh uh which should be a slam dunk
this Broadband tour you know he he can't
win support because the more he's in
public the more people become concerned
I think that part of the reason I think
I don't think that that's a compelling
issue for the American people like I
don't think you really think
especially covid there were so many
rural communities that struggled what
everyone else said you can just do
things online and communities like it's
like I think of West Virginia and all
the mountains like you could could not
have school online because there is not
there are communities that don't have
internet at home and we and it took us
six months to get internet yeah both
locations it's insane and it cost tens
of thousands of dollars to get them to
actually trench and then lay the lines
down to the to the note or whatever it
was nuts I'm not saying it's like the
single biggest issue
leave your state that wants to develop
business I mean you might be able to
speak to this more but
if you're trying to lure young people in
you're saying oh you can work remotely
now well then you need guaranteed solid
internet access so it's not enough to
have affordable housing or people who I
land like if you cannot work from home
then the idea that you would move to a
rural State like West Virginia Maine
Wyoming to a certain extent I feel like
there are I feel like there are issues
that are more motivating that are more
top of mind I'm not saying it's the only
issue I'm just saying I think it does
make a big difference especially in the
post-covet era because I feel like
people now now are still feeling
pressures from uh inflation and I do
think that one of the things that's most
most saline most pressing on people's
minds is the stuff with the with LG with
this year's pride month yeah in June in
particular yeah again like I said I was
I was out in California a couple weeks
ago talking to my friends that are not
uh you know super politically active and
they are talking about the you know the
things that are going on in schools and
stuff that's going on at Target and
that's something because it's it deals
with kids and parents are laser focused
on the thing that is going to most make
them anxious or concerned about their
kids and I think that that kind of stuff
is the stuff that if he were going to be
able to produce a compelling message
that
could help his his numbers I feel like
that's where it would be and I don't
think that he is in us in a place where
or I don't think the Democrats at all
are in a place where they could actually
say look we do condemn these types of
things and I think that that's probably
one of the reasons why he's got such bad
poll numbers thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time